[Music]
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 64th episode of dirty
chess tricks
now everybody knows the legal trap in
the king's pawn opening
but very few people know that
the same idea and patent can be applied
to different chess opening
for example in my chair strap 45
i have covered the same idea against the
scandinavian defense
and in this video we are going to see
a high-profile legal trick against
the alakan defense
the critical position arises after the
following
opening more order e4
knight to f6 here the main lines start
with
e5 however my recommendation is
you play this straight forward move
knight to c3
at this junction if black continue with
e5 then we can respond with
knight to f3 and i have covered this
three nights defense
in my dirty chess tricks 43 and 44
episode with some detail analysis
so if you haven't check it out you can
definitely
watch those videos however
the main move in this position is d5
attacking the e4 pawn
one more time so accordingly white
needs to take it and after knight
captures d5
white start developing pieces with the
attack
bishop to c4 attacking the knight
knight to b6 counter-attacking the
bishop
bishop to b3 and now
as per the online database the most
popular choice by black camp is
knight to c6 not only controlling
the d4 square but later on
black can indeed continue with knight to
d4
and nabbing the white bishop pair
okay knight to f3 trying to get
d4 in so obviously black has to stop
it and accordingly e5 is a fitting reply
claiming in the center and once again
taking the control
of the d4 square
well white has to develop the last piece
so accordingly
d3 liberating the dark square
and now bishop to g4 pinning down the
knight
threatening knight to d4 something
which white need to address immediately
pay attention guys because here comes
the movement
which sets up the legal trap against the
alakan defend
and that start with h3
hitting the bishop bishop to h5 so
obviously black doesn't want to
surrender the bishop pair
and g4 makes white position very weak
on the king side but guess what
this is exactly what he's hoping for and
not so surprising if you check the
online database
there are more than 20 games goes into
this direction
where white has this lethal queen
sacrifice
yup you guessed it knight captures e5
boom
what a move well
not only white is a clear pawn up but
he is attacking the black bishop so
pretty much
black has a force reply he has to take
the queen
with bishop captures d1
and after that yup our legal trap
territory
bishop captures f7 jack king to e7
and now the star move bishop to g5
well few moves of the black are pretty
much forceful now
he has to play the only move king to d6
and now if white is not careful then he
can lose this game
if we continue with bishop captures
queen
as after the following sequence knight
catches e5
attacking the two bishop and when you
say
one of them let's say bishop to h4
after the following trade knight
captures app 7
and the move rook captures d1 if you
count the pieces
black emerged with a knight against two
pawn
which is obviously with the careful play
a winning advantage
to the black camp
so regaining the queen is a big time
mistake in this position
however white can go for the mole and
accordingly
knight to e4 is a wonderful
attacking reply
and i must say that when the first time
i see the sequence
i thought wow white is investing
quite a bit material but is it going to
be enough
well let's find out
once again black king has the only reply
he has to
take this knot
after that another forcing move
f4 king has to go to the d4 square
because if he goes to the f5 square
then there is a mate in one guys
and i hope you indeed see it
knight to g3 wonderful
smoothers made so that is
right out of the equation the king mary
journey continued with
king to d4
and after this it looks like white is
running
out of the steam but sometimes
chess beauty can surprise you
and believe it or not but white has a
very calm move in this position
rook captures demon
and amazing enough it creates two deadly
threats
number one white is attacking the black
queen
and number two white is all set to play
the move c3
and then checkmate the power king
first let's check out what happens if
black tried to save the queen
let's say queen to d7 which is in fact
a big time mistake as now
there is made in two guys
so before i move on i want you to pause
this video
and find out this wonderful checkmate
are you ready let's start the first
movie is very obvious
c3 check and after king to e3
i hope you indeed see this deciding
plural
f5 a pictures
checkmate on the board
well the same goes if he continue with
bishop to e7
trying to defend the queen on another
way
this time we have a checkmate in three
and the sequence start with this
beautiful
king move on the e2 square
which highlight how poorly black king
has been placed
and no matter however black plays
next move is going to be c3 and the
checkmate
is on the horizon
last but not least there are more than
12 games
continue with queen captures g5
which looks more logical in this
position
black tried to eliminate as many as
species
so the white attack can be neutralized
but surprisingly this is still not
enough once again white has this
lethal check and after king to e3
and the move f captures g5
as you can see i have highlighted by the
arrows
white has a simple plan namely
castle on the king side with rook to f3
followed by the checkmate sequence
now to highlight how simply white can
checkmate black king
i like to show you a model game where a
2000 plus rated black opponent
continue with knight to e5
a double attack but
white doesn't bother about it and he
continued with
castle on the king side
well there is no time to play knight
captures f7
so black played knight captures d3
trying to attack the center knight and
time being
white saves the knight with knight to g3
okay checkmate is coming up with rook to
f3
so black stop it with knight to e5
but i think here white deliver this
excellent blow rook to d4
threatening another checkmate with rook
to e1
so once again black is obliged to stop
it
with knight to d3 but now
a very cute sequence rook to e4
jack king to d2
and the final finishing blow yup
rook to e2 and finally
black king dance comes to a poor end
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile legal trick against the
alakan
remember in this position play the move
h3
and once bishop goes to the h5
give your opponent this root shock with
knight captures e5
sacrificing your queen but getting the
full point
with lot of fun over the board
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care